Repeating everything that i've already
told you about my friend and golly
obviously captain america was important
Welcome back everyone is charlie this will be
my full marvel she-hulk episode one video there
were all kinds of easter eggs and references to
a bunch of different things including all the
way back to incredible hulk with edward norton
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new
to the channel i'll be doing videos for all the
episodes be sure to subscribe to get them we're
also doing a giveaway for disney plus memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
just post your favorite easter egg or moment from
the episode on the video careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet we'll just
start at the beginning and work our way through
shot by shot talking about easter eggs and wtf
moments as we go along speaking of wtf moments
they dropped an f-bomb in the post-credits scene
i think that's one of the first times not the
first time but one of the first times that they've
dropped it in a marvel production particularly a
marvel series deadpool 3 will be the exception to
that because it'll be rated r but also connection
to she-hulk because deadpool like she-hulk breaks
the fourth wall she did a number of times in this
episode but the funny thing is is that she-hulk
actually broke the fourth wall in the comics
many many years before deadpool ever did so
technically deadpool is copying her so can't
wait for them to meet in avengers 5 kang dynasty
and to joke about that together breaking the
fourth wall again the episode title was a normal
amount of rage a reference to their relative rage
levels as they hulk out but also she literally
says those words in the episode during their
training montage she has a normal amount of rage
they actually started off with the newest marvel
intro adding jane foster thor to it miss marvel
and moon knight doctor strange 2 footage as well
they do that in each new marvel series or marvel
movie where they'll like add little bits from the
previous marvel production to the title in all
the promos they also have a green version of the
marvel studios logo we'll see if that eventually
shows up in an episode the funny way they start
the opening scene is making you think that she's
breaking the fourth wall just kind of setting you
up for the idea that she will continue to break
the fourth ball many times but she's not actually
breaking the fourth wall in this opening moment
here she's just talking to people who are behind
the camera for big comic book fans a lot of her
speech sounds a little bit like a who watches the
watchmen kind of speech and a lot of her speech
also mirrors the speech that the hulk gave her
about her responsibility like people in power have
a responsibility to protect people without power
she name drops having a savage look which is a
reference to her becoming savage she-hulk like
she does in the comics like that's literally the
name of one of her titles savage she-hulk there
are a couple references later in the episode where
she talks about not thinking that she has an alter
ego like i don't think i have one but that's just
foreshadowing because she definitely has an alter
ego we just haven't met her yet for most part in
marvel comics history she hook is depicted the
way that you see her in the courtroom here like
she's a green lawyer that represents superheroes
but for the most time she exists kind of like in a
professor banner smart hulk kind of way in some of
the newer comics they have depicted her in a more
savage she-hulk like full hulk kind of way like
she does have a full hulk form it looks way more
muscular than this form when she hulks out for
the first time like when they're doing the origin
story some of the scenes are built to look just
like scenes from the 1970s incredible hulk series
with the practical effects one of the differences
in the way that they actually do the effects for
her hulk and for bruce banner's hulk though is
that with the exception for like this one opening
scene bruce banner is mostly all motion capture
like anytime you see his version of the hulk he's
always wearing the man canceling suit with dots
all over it the different way that they pull off
some of the effects for she-hulk though is that
they actually have like a super tall woman who's
like in olympic level shape walking around on set
that they use as a body double reference one of
the downsides though is because they don't have
like an extra year to work on the special effects
is you can kind of tell when they zoom in on their
mouths they don't quite nail down the motion so
it kind of hinders their performances a little bit
but for the most part none of the special effects
weaknesses really bothered me that much when they
name-dropped the law firm g-k-l and h that's
the law firm that she works for in the comics
they're also the people that are representing the
defendants in the trial that she's prosecuting at
the end of the episode this is the head of the law
firm he becomes so impressed with her performance
during that court case that he eventually winds
up hiring her i believe a lot of that will be
covered in episode two then she actually breaks
the fourth wall for the first time to reveal that
she's already become the hook like oh surprise we
already had the origin story and they flash back
to show you how it all happened so just to chart
this in the timeline they said that it doesn't
take place that long after avengers end game like
it takes place after the shangshi post credits
scene wang is also going to cameo in the series
as we've seen in all the trailers he'll help chart
the timeline a little bit too with some of his
references so i believe all the stuff you see with
wong in the trailers is meant to be before the
events of doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness
so we're talking like the same year as avengers
end game happen not that much time has gone by
when they're in the car bruce banner talks about
his arm healing on its own but that's because of
his game abilities he has the suppressor that he
built that keeps him in human form but it doesn't
completely negate all of his game of powers
thus the arm slowly healing some of you may have
figured out the flamin hot cheetos joke too the
whole thing with the flamin hot cheetos and the
chopsticks is meant to be an oscar isaac joke in
real life like it's something that oscar isaac did
in real life just eating flamin hot cheetos with
chopsticks someone took a video and posted it and
it just blew up on social media so there are a
couple points in this episode where they call back
to that like later in the episode you see them
eating more flamin hot cheetos with chopsticks
bruce banner references another relative of
theirs named ched who's also a genius he might
be the person in the post credit scene with the
ponytail but it could be like a totally different
character that we haven't met yet he doesn't sound
like he's from the comics like there is no chad
that's related to bruce banner in the comics they
do the funny real-life theory about steve rogers
being a virgin for over 100 years till the end
of avengers end game when he went back in time
to stay with that version of peggy carter this
is another example of marvel doing real-life fan
theories and making them canon in the series
they just did the same thing with ant-man
legit canonizing the thanos theory now he made a
joke about it but them having the character talk
about it in a marvel production is them canonizing
the theory to the mcu effectively let me address
the elephants i've heard a lot of chatter out
there asking why i didn't shrink down go in and
kill thanos in a really creative way first of
all gross secondly it's much more complicated
than that allow me to explain if only we had the
time i cannot wait for like the next weird fan
theory to pop up in the next couple of years and
then work it into one of the other marvel series
like they're going to continue doing stuff like
that then there's this whole teaser with one of
the grand master of ships from sakaar it's the
exact same type of ship the grand master had
the hulk later says that it was probably a
messenger bringing some sort of message for them
from sakaar but he'll have to find out about it
later that's just a teaser for future episodes
like yeah they'll pay that off in a future
episode i did a video a little while ago
about the possibility of them doing more planet
hulk and world war hulk easter eggs because later
in the episode he talks about being full hulk
like kind of losing his mind and being in full
hulk form for over two years the early theory is
that during those two years when he was full hulk
banner doesn't remember the hulk actually having
a child with another woman from sakaar and that'll
be their way of doing a version of scar son
of hulk from the comics but let me know in
the comments what you think the message was that
they were trying to bring to him from sakaar like
what was so important that an alien ship would
just show up on planet earth to find the hulk
then they clarify how she gets contaminated with
hulk's blood like how he's capable of bleeding
they both get cut in the accident in bruce
banner's wristband that was keeping him in human
form gets disabled temporarily allowing him to
bleed and her to be infected with his gamma blood
and like i reference the 1970s incredible hulk tv
series with the practical hulk effects they kind
of do a version of that when she hulks out for
the first time and then stomps off into the woods
and i believe this is also the first time that
we've seen bruce banner hulk hulk out practically
with effects instead of then doing just full cg
replacement the whole scene of her coming too
stomping through the woods finding the bar in the
middle of nowhere feels like it's right out of an
episode of the 1970s incredible hulk tv series
when she walks through the bar there's a qr code
on the right the qr code actually leads you to a
savage she-hulk comic book that you can get for
free on the marvel website they did this easter
egg during all the moon night episodes or at least
most of the moon night episodes there were always
qr codes in the background that would just give
you free comic books there's a couple references
on the chalkboard too like there's a bunch of
graffiti here there's a miss marvel symbol and
there's the word green just another reference to
her becoming she-hulk she hooks out again losing
it on the dudes who won't stop coming at her then
passes out waking up after the hook has taken her
to his hideaway in mexico the way they explained
this iron man helped him build this place after
the events of the first avengers movie is sort of
like their science bros place where they hung out
like it's meant to be a big science bros reference
gave him all of his gear pretty much because the
hulk isn't rich or anything like that he even
jokes about that too like tony's saying that he
would come back and take it from him like this is
only on loan i'm gonna come back for this someday
which is also kind of meant to be sad like he's
remembering his friend and being sad that he's
dead but that's also the reason for the broken
ultron helmet in the house there if you didn't
spot it that's not one of iron man's old armors
that's actually an old helmet that ultron wore
in one of his early forms and iron man and hulk
put it there just as a reminder for their hubris
like the events of avengers age of ultron ultron
basically happening because they were too reckless
with their experiments on the mind stone also
the other reason for them putting this place in
mexico is because it's outside of u.s jurisdiction
meaning that it's out of the jurisdiction of
thunderbolt ross or it was until the formation
of the world security council he also clarifies
that this is the same lab that he referenced
during avengers end game that he spent during
the blip trying to become professor hulk and
they finally answer how he was able to heal his
arm he basically says that the way that the gamma
reacts with she-hulk's body is different from the
way the gamma acts on his body and something about
the way that interacts with her allows him to use
her dna to basically heal his arm completely now
i think this is them just setting up that some of
her powers will be a little bit different from his
eventually like they're just building some room
for that like oh this is why she does things
differently because the gamma powers work a
little bit differently on her when he burns
her blood samples that's also a reference back
to incredible hulk when stan lee had his cameo
seen and hulked out himself because of the soda
pop that had been contaminated with hulk's blood
also the leader was stealing a lot of his blood
like he had samples of all the hulk's blood trying
to recreate his powers which is how he created the
abomination eventually which they later referenced
is also the way that he became the leader as
well he was contaminated with hulk's blood
a lot of people wondering when they're gonna
bring the leader back they can still do that
anytime they want but obviously that's just meant
to dovetail with the idea that abomination is a
big character during this series like one of the
big trials that she has to do is representing him
in court trying to free him of his charges when
he references the multi-year journey that she's
on that's a reference to her entering the mcu just
in general like in eventually being in avengers
5 kang dynasty in avengers 6 secret wars in a
couple years we'll also probably wind up getting
a she-hulk season 2. she references pixar's inside
out movie just confirming that pixar also exists
in this universe i think they may have referenced
pixar at least once before we knew that star wars
and lucasfilm existed in the mcu so i think
disney is also meant to exist too but i can't
remember the last time we saw a disney reference
but obviously everybody knows that disney owns
marvel and star wars in real life like disney owns
all these properties they also try to explain that
she starts out just being the professor hulk
balance version of the character being all
chatty but like i mentioned earlier i think this
is meant to be foreshadowing because she says you
know i think i don't have an alternate persona
i think that's just foreshadowing for her going
full hulk becoming like a mindless version of
the character in the future if you haven't read
a lot of the hulk comics like there are alternate
personas of the she-hulk like she has a gray form
just like the hulk has a gray joe fix-it form so
based on their emotional state just their psyche
in general they can take completely alternate
personas because of when this takes place in the
timeline he says he was wrestling with an alter
ego for 10 years that's a reference to the events
of the incredible hulk right after he became the
hulk for the first time when he references black
widow's lullaby they've referenced that many times
in marvel movies like it's kind of a joke now most
recently in thor ragnarok i already mentioned
the planet hulk references that he makes during
this when he's talking about being blacked out
basically being full hulk for over two years
i think that has more to do with the sakhar ship
that showed up at the beginning of the episode
during their training montage she says the title
of the episode literally she has a normal amount
of rage they make all the jokes about spandex
which they pay off in the post credit scenes
like in the end credits when they're drawing
them at the big bulk store just buying a whole
bunch of extra pants they have the joke about
hulk throwing the boulder into outer space
just to remind you that he has the full strength
of the hulk in his professor hulk form which is a
little bit different from the comics like he's a
little bit weaker when he's in the balance state
usually he's more powerful in full hulk state but
i think what they're saying in the mcu is that as
professor hulk he still has access to a hundred
percent of his strength it's just that during a
lot of this especially when they start fighting
each other he's holding back big time which also
i think is eventually going to get to some world
war hulk references because you do see a lot of
she-hulk versus hulk during the episode like this
is clearly foreshadowing the two of them going
at each other in the future him pushing her off
the cliff is also just to show you how she's now
impervious to most physical damage like you
can still hurt the hook but it takes a lot
a lot of force their biggest weakness is mostly
against psychological attacks like professor x
invading their mind they have all the jokes about
them getting drunk together like they have to
drink a giant dump truck full of liquor just to
get a little buzzed but he winds up making a bunch
more science bros references to him and iron man
just hanging out getting all sad about him dying
saying that they spent a lot of time at this
beach house and just hanging out with apparently
iron man getting super drunk complaining about
captain america a whole lot i think that's also
a little bit of a wink at the demon in the bottle
story line which they also kind of did a version
of during iron man 2. you also noticed that they
carved their initials on the bar which she also
does later at the end of the episode they continue
the joke of captain america being a virgin her big
theory which they eventually do pay off in the
post-credits scene i'll talk about that in a
second too because that's another example of them
canonizing a theory that just sounded really good
the only thing i found weird about this whole
montage here especially this funny moment
is the fact that she still got a hangover you
would think that the gammon powers would burn
off the alcohol in their systems so fast that
that wouldn't be a thing we also find out that
just because of the state that she's in right
now mentally she can transform into hulk and back
into human form on command but i think that's
also kind of misleading too i think eventually
she will like fully lose it and not be able to do
that like there are all these jokes at the end of
the episode too where she's like i will never ever
have to do this again i can be jennifer walters i
will never need the she-hulk powers ever again
which is just meant to be a joke that she will
like literally have to hulk out right after
that so anytime a character just keeps going
on and on about how they're totally in control it
means they will probably not always be in control
when she references him quoting a comic book
though who's going to protect the world if it
isn't people like us i think that's actually meant
to be a quote from the classic avengers comics
and it's more meant to foreshadow her future
crossing over with the avengers but also be
jokes about her being a lawyer as well like she
will be defending people just in court but also
eventually in the avengers movies like avengers
5 she will literally be defending the earth in a
more traditional style when she references secret
government contractor squad obviously that's
meant to be an avengers reference but it's also a
reference to the sokovia accords because when they
signed the accords in captain america civil war
technically that made the avengers agents of the
world security council but i think it's also meant
to be a sly reference to thunderbolts who are
literally on the government's payroll like during
falcon and winter soldier when val is explaining
who she is what she does who she works for she
says that everything she's doing is sanctioned
by the us government even though it's meant to
be super shady and then they have their big hulk
versus she-hulk fight scene where they just go at
each other like i said he's really holding back
here but like he shows her how to do a thunderclap
and she does her own version of that disabling him
with some sonic blasts when she's hooking out here
too this is also a pose right out of the comics
she breaks the fourth ball again later
when he finally agrees to let her go
apparently his nickname for her is fuzzball
i think maybe that's meant to be a reference
to her curly hair a lot of people wondering why
it's straight when she becomes the hulk i think
they just want her to look more like comic book
she-hook when she is fully hulked out and then it
transitions back to present day with her breaking
the fourth wall telling us like okay finally i've
explained everything to you and then they set
up the big joke with her saying that she's never
gonna have to be she look again i'm never gonna
need to do any of this i can totally be a normal
person right after which titania busts through the
courtroom where she has to hook out and stop her
when she says her name is jennifer walters
attorney at law that's literally in the official
title of a show like she-hulk attorney at law i
believe the whole idea here though is that titania
wasn't coming for she-hulk herself it looked like
she was coming for one of the defendants or the
judge because if you look later in the end credit
scene the drawings are based on courtroom drawings
that you see them drawing at the beginning
of the trial like there's a person in each
courtroom drawing the proceedings but they're also
animated in the style of she-hulk comic book art
they're also meant to depict the events of that
particular trial so i think when we get to future
episodes in each episode the end credits will
change to just depict each trial that she's in
during each particular episode and in this one you
see her hold up an avengers mug with lipstick on
it i think titania busting through had something
to do with the lipstick on the mug if you're not
a big comic book reader though titania is one of
she-hulk's biggest villains in the comics but the
way the actor said they're playing the character
on the show is that she does have super powers
like she is kind of a super villain but she's like
the worst version of an influencer that you can
imagine who winds up hating she-hulk and i think
it has something to do with she-hulk becoming so
popular like someone recorded her big takedown in
the trial and posted it on social media so it made
her as jennifer walters she-hulk super popular so
i think titania wants revenge against her later
in the episodes and that just becomes a bigger
and bigger thing but she also talked about her
character titania's character eventually being on
the thunderbolts eventually so they might do that
too you also notice one of the partners from gklh
who's her boss in the trailers sees what she's
doing and is really impressed by her but then
when the actual end credits start they depict
her transformation into she-hulk and like i said
they depict the events of that particular trial
you see the recently broken wall in the
background you see your friend nikki there
her in the elevator as she hulk i think is also
meant to be a reference to episode two steph
where she joins the law firm g k l and h who are
representing the defendants like the other person
there who's her new boss was really impressed
by her we see hulk bring her boxes and boxes
of cheese puffs at this big bulk store while she's
buying a bunch of new pants obviously they'll give
her a version of the comic book costume like you
see it in all the trailers that might not happen
until later episodes like hulk will eventually
create the special comic book suit and give it
to her towards the later episodes you also see her
wearing that when she goes up against daredevil
this is just hulk fixing his broken lab equipment
apparently with a whole bunch of duct tape they
continue the joke about her captain america theory
with a huge hand-drawn chart board like she's gone
full charlie day meme the women on the board here
obviously peggy carter the woman from the uso
tour who we find out at the end of the episode
is the woman he actually lost his virginity to
the other woman up on the right here is sharon
carter in the question mark i think is meant to
be the other version of peggy carter that he went
back to time traveling at the end of avengers end
game i believe this dinner here that she-hulk
is having is meant to be a family dinner this
person with a ponytail might be like a brother
of hers it might be like another mystery cousin
she doesn't have any brothers in the comics so
i think it might be like a brand new person to
introduce for the series there's a shield logo
on her legal documents for a case it's probably
a reference to episode 2 in the damage control
prison that they're keeping abomination in they
actually referenced this prison during the miss
marvel series the picture of the dating app is
just meant to be a reference to later episodes
when she actually tries to have a legit personal
life while still being in she-hulk form
like dating as she-hulk it's in all the
trailers like they have all those jokes about
the dudes who want them some death by snooze new
if you don't know what that is it is one of the
best jokes ever death by crush pelvis you will
enjoy it so much but you will definitely die at
the end of it the picture of her lifting weights
in the venice t-shirt is a reference to venice
beach in los angeles where a lot of bodybuilders
hang out and work out on the actual beach then
this picture of all the cosplayers as the avengers
thor iron man captain america hulk trying to get
pictures with she-hulk on hollywood boulevard in
front of man's chinese theater is actually a thing
in real life like you'll find a lot of cosplayers
there charging four pictures with them you may
remember andrew garfield actually did a joke about
that dressed in a spider-man cosplay costume
when he was on jimmy kimmel one day in her on
the court steps is also from the comics they also
turned part of this into the poster for the series
then they have the post-credit scene joke where
they pay off captain america not actually being a
virgin like they finally canonize it hulk finally
answering the question when he says 1943 the woman
on the uso tour that's just meant to help you
chart the timeline because they want to say this
before he started his relationship with peggy
carter like before they actually became a thing
and they end with her dropping an f-bomb pretty
rare to see someone drop an f-bomb in a marvel
production but if you spotted any other easter
eggs or references in the episode that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below
in the comments i didn't spot any really huge
cameos obviously a lot of big references and
references to the 1970s incredible hulk tv series
my full episode 2 video will post next week after
they release it i believe the title is whose show
is this they did release the rest of the episode
titles but some of them are out of order so i
don't know if this is the actual correct order of
the episodes there's a bunch of really cool stuff
coming up so make sure you enable alerts for my
channel so you don't miss any of that i'll name
a giveaway winner in my next big marvel video too
everyone click here for my new she-hulk daredevil
and world war hulk trailer video and click
here for my loki season 2 first look breakdown
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!